hier eine sehr schöne frage und zwar von
sterne agee sternenstaub maruti strich
nein days to screen die frage nämlich
wie alt bist du werden
die auf seide was geht
die begrüßung aber ja hier begrüßt euch
einen maxime hat er mal wieder zum
friseur sollte und ich hab noch nie im
video so angefangen aber heute gibt es
mal wieder anfragen video ich bin mit
meinem dad das könnt ihr vielleicht hier
im hintergrund erkennen und es gibt ein
frage video weil ich natürlich nicht
vorproduziert haben wir kennen ich habe
heute noch besonders kreativen fragen
gefragt und der sich fragt direktor was
ziemlich ausgefallen ist und zwar was
würdest du eher machen mit pixel wohl
von crafter in eine wg ziehen oder eine
familie gründen
ich weiß nicht ob das so einem moment
verzogen fall ist was ich jetzt machen
würde weil jetzt im moment ist ja klar
würde ich mit denen würde ich mit dem
duzen wohnung ziehen weil ich kann jetzt
keine familie gebrauchen aber an sich
würde ich mich natürlich dafür
entscheiden dass ich eine familie gründe
weil ich glaube das ist eine unglaublich
schöne sache irgendwann meine eigene
familie zu haben was ich hätte natürlich
nicht jetzt haben wollen würde so aber
an sich ist das glaub ich mega coole
sache und dann wird deshalb will ich das
nicht
für so viele gemeinsame wg auf eben
diese möglichkeit irgendwann mal eine
familie zu planen
deine meinung zur gdl und der guten
sache möchte gerne wenig salehi anhören
also ich für meinen teil bin absolut
kein fan von julians blog ich würde
nicht sagen dass das keine muss weil man
natürlich humor nicht irgendwo begrenzen
sollte aber mir ist das definitiv ein
deutlich zu
also ich finde das einfach nicht lustig
klar ich sage jetzt nicht dass es keine
dass kein humor mehr oder so was gott
jetzt überbelichtet auf sich so zu
überbelichteten aber ist jetzt auch
freunde seien also ich würde nicht sagen
dass das keine more ist aber es ist
einfach lustig und ich find es definitiv
nicht mein fall
nächste frage von alina welcher song es
bei dem momentan den dauerschleife also
grundsätzlich bin ich jemand der
überhaupt nicht sind auf streife hören
kann
also mir hängt das institut aus wenden
die zweimal hintereinander höre ich weiß
nicht da gibt es solche und solche leute
manche hören
zwei tage lang nur auf dauer streife das
gleiche lied aber ich kann so was nicht
was ich sehr gerne höre ist dass die
free style font weight watchers finde
ich mir ja lustig das ist natürlich
textliche schwachsinn und sowas noch
zwei weitere lieder die ich ganz cool
finde ist catch and release von matt
simmons was auch immer wie man es
ausspricht
und da es laut kit buch finde ich auch
noch ganz cool aber wie gesagt ich habe
euch recht ein breites spektrum hier
auch jack johnson und so was also ich
habe mich da ich nicht fest ich alle wo
sieht so lange so gut ist eine sehr
interessante frage von 1 chris füße die
schuldig wenn du kein video bringst oder
bringst du oder zwingst und ich manchmal
ein video zu machen
das werde ich öfter so gefragt würde die
ich schreibe also kein verdammt leute
haben wieder kein video also an sich ist
es so wenn ich kein bock habt ein video
zu machen
dann mache ich kein video das
wisst ihr wahrscheinlich auch wenn ich
schon länger zu schaut was manchmal auch
kein video kommt aber bei mir ist es
immer so dass ich muss mich ja auch
selbst motivieren ich meine jetzt beim
video machen habe ich spaß beim
schneiden habe ich auch spaß aber
dadurch dass ich was einfach komplett
dumm ist von mir übrigens dadurch dass
ich nicht nicht mal einen tag vor
produzieren immer alles tag aktuell
mache ist es immer so dass ich manchmal
ist einfach so ein bisschen aufschieben
so obwohl ich eigentlich spaß daran habe
also kann ich zu beantworten ich zwinge
mich nicht manchmal wie das manchmal
muss man so ein arsch treten aber ich
habe trotzdem spaß aber also also ich
mach's nicht aus irgendwelchen
finanziellen interessen sonst war es
absolut nicht aber manchmal muss ich
mich halt selbst motivieren aber ich
glaube das kennt ihr auch und ich finde
gerade so was wie youtube ist halt auch
was wo regeln wichtig ist und ich habe
ja auch spaß dabei aber so wirklich kein
bau kappen video zu machen mache ich
auch kein video hier eine sehr
interessante frage vom lieben kt corp
was hältst du von dem ganzen brief
derzeit auf youtube mit wesentliche frau
und baby da die lions julien co und der
community finde ich ist eine gute frage
weil einerseits ist es berechtigt dass
man da ein bisschen aus teil so sagen so
weil sie schon die ein oder andere
moralisch ist nicht ganz
unbedenklichkeit ausnutzung halt
irgendwie profit zu machen
andererseits ich meine es ist jetzt auch
nicht so unendlich krass aber es wird
schon heftig fiel auf den ruhm gehabt
finde ich ich selbst mache ja auch mal
so ein job ab und an aber ich bin jetzt
wird anhand der so irgendwie nur hashtag
we hate ag oder sowas ins leben ruft
also ich finde es ist wichtig dass man
leute darauf aufmerksam macht auch gerne
mit humor und sowas dass das was sie
machen nicht so cool ist also ja aber
einfach so grundlos und quasi ohne pause
zu helfen finde ich dann schon wieder
ein bisschen krass um hier eine sehr
schöne frage und zwar von sterne agee
sternenstaub
strikt nein der ist durch cree die fragt
nämlich wie alt möchtest du werden das
finde ich ist eine sehr interessante
frage
also ich habe jetzt nicht so peter pan
syndrom allerdings unendlich alt so zu
werden und so richtig gebrechlich zu
werden ist dann halt irgendwie auch
schon wieder nicht schön
wobei ich mir natürlich auch nicht
irgendwie vorzeitig das das leben nehmen
würde oder sowas weil das wäre einfach
zu krass für die leute die man die man
zurücklässt und so was also wenn man es
jetzt einfach mal rational auch wirklich
wird es auch niemals machen aber ich
glaube es bis 70 75 oder so was ist das
leben
cool da kannst du dich auf den früchten
die dein vorheriges leben getragen hat
denn arbeiten und sonst was kann man
sich dann ausruhen und also fast so von
meinem dad er hat unheimlich viel
gearbeitet immer werte quasi zwei
vollzeitjobs gehabt wo wirklich viel
gearbeitet hat das ist jetzt so sein
lohn also hat jetzt einen einen job
abgelegt und machen auch den anderen so
also eine woche arbeiten eine woche
sagte auch dazu und das ist auf jeden
fall echt krass also weil der kann jetzt
erstmalig nach 25 jahren nur zwei
wirklich fordernde vollzeitjobs hatte
kann er sich so ausruhen ich denke mal
das ist auch echt eine wichtige zeit so
wo du einfach genießen kannst so wofür
du gearbeitet hast wenn man fragt sich
wofür arbeitet man so und das ist
vielleicht eine möglichkeit
besonders schön ist es natürlich wenn du
wenn du auch im alter noch jemanden hast
mit dem glücklich besser sonst was und
insofern ist das auf jeden fall so bis
70 75 komplett unbedenklich aber wenn
dann halt wirklich alt gebrechlich
willst deine freunde deine
geliebten menschen so aus seinem
jahrgang so langsam weg stellen als das
irgendwie auch schon krass also ich weiß
es nicht ich würde so 70 75 werden
wollen
aber dann würde ich wahrscheinlich doch
älterwerden für meine kinder sonst was
einfach das ist verdammt schnell die
frage aber sehr kreativ auf jeden fall
die habe ich jetzt etwas länger
beantwortet ja dann würde ich sagen was
auch von heute ich hab es ein bisschen
kürzer gehalten und irgendwie probiert
immer eine andere perspektive zu machen
meine haare sind zu schrecklich lange
ist nur noch so viel probiert das ein
bisschen ein bisschen kürzer zu halten
weil ich zum hochladen mussten waren wie
gesagt und es ist so schlecht